it's January 2017 so it's time for
another monthly update video but since
it's the beginning of a new year I'm
going to talk about 2016 as a whole and
then also talk about what's coming up in
2017 with what's going on in January
sandwiched in between as usual I like to
begin by talking about three big things
that I'd like to put on your horizon
right at the beginning of the month one
of these is that we've just brought out
a new course in the reason I owe Academy
world views and values so I'll talk a
little bit about that in the January
section the second is I'm hoping by end
of the month to have a little short book
on stoic dog matta that is sayings or
ideas that are ready to hand about anger
ready to be downloaded by people that
that's find it useful third big thing is
that on the twelfth 7pm we'll have our
first talk of the year in the renewed
worlds of speculative fiction series is
a local talk here in the Milwaukee area
it will be on Phillip Jose farmers river
world series and so it's part of the
worlds of speculative fiction series
that is some of the big stuff we've got
on the horizon so let's talk about 2016
as a whole there's been an awful lot of
complaining about what a dismal year it
was by a lot of people but I think it's
actually been not so bad of a year when
when you look at some of the other ones
and for us at reason I oh it's been a
very important year of building and
getting a lot of important things done I
gave a number of talks I didn't even
bother to count them up there somewhere
in the you know the double digits
probably I would say somewhere between
30 and 40 talks at various locations
places audiences maybe even more than
that this this past year we have that
worlds of speculative fiction series
that was quite you know popular and
we've been renewed for another year of
that we did the Philosopher's in the
midst of history series with partnering
with another library that's a quarterly
series that has also been renewed so
we're doing for new philosophers for
that coming up and I give a number of
talks on stoicism and Aristotle at
various venues over the course of the
year as well I got quite active more
than previous years in doing one on work
with clients some of it was tutoring
I've actually got quite a few really
interesting projects underway with some
regular tutoring with clients doing some
pretty cool stuff as well as the the
normal hate I I need to study for this
exam can you help me out dr. Sadler can
of tutoring philosophical counseling
I've been helping out a number of other
clients and some of them are ongoing
some of them have successfully worked
through whatever issues they came to me
with which is always great to see been
doing some executive coaching as well
that's that's also very interesting and
stimulating to do I've been engaging in
quite a bit of what we could call public
writing I took over the editor position
at stoicism today's or the flagship
journal for the modern stoic movement
and I wrote a few pieces for that but I
edited an awful lot and solicited even
more than than we had I successfully
resuscitated my main blog or exes do you
know NTK and probably the second half of
the year that's going along pretty well
I'm happy about that half hour Hagel
blog I've been writing regularly there
towards the end of the year I started
writing for another blog called the
policy of truth which is the blog
belonging to good friend of mine ear fun
and it's really an interesting community
I've been following that blog for a long
time and so I finally said maybe I
should start writing something and I
also started answer
Cora questions that that's sort of a
sideline it's not so much blogging as
public writing in a different way I have
been also working on some academic
writing I got more done in terms of
doing presentations than actually
sending things out for review from
journals and publication I've been
working a lot of stuff having to do with
Aristotle and anger some things having
to do with the Stoics and anger and also
I did in fact get something published
this year which is a book chapter in a
book on st. handsome and mine has to do
with and some and the dialectic between
mercy and justice has discussed in his
prayers did a lot of video work as
anybody who's been following my channel
knows as a matter of fact I not only
have been doing video work in this
channel but I also opened up a new
channel my history of ideas channel that
you can find all these great Epictetus
close reading videos in and I'm going to
be adding more things in there so that I
did an entire series sort of like the
half-hour Hagel stuff but taking
epictetus is enchiridion and going
through it line by line chapter by
chapter i'm very proud of that series
half-hour Hagel I got a lot of videos
done I didn't manage to get six every
month but most months I did and so we've
made some great progress we're almost at
the very very halfway point of the work
which is great because we've already put
in close to three years on that project
a lot of core concept videos I did quite
a few for Aristotle the Nicomachean
ethics I wanted to round out my
discussion of the Nick and mckean ethics
I did a lot of Epictetus videos as well
core concept videos I did a number of
st. handsome one's on the Manolo gian
and a few other core concept videos here
and there and I I also did a few
personal videos perhaps not as many as i
would have liked and i started a series
of sort of frequently asked question
I got one of them done about you know
can you do a video on this I'll be doing
more of those in the year to come I also
did quite a bit of teaching all of it
was was online I brought out some
courses in our reason I owe Moodle and
that was that was good we've decided
that we're not going to keep up with
that for the year to come because we're
concentrating all of our efforts on the
reason I owe teachable Academy that's a
platform that lets us do a lot more of
what we we wanted to be able to do with
online teaching which is to offer
classes that people can take whether
they're students or lifelong learners
working professionals worldwide anywhere
that they want to my videos are a big
component to that but I provide lesson
pages quizzes discussion questions
handouts worksheets all sorts of really
cool stuff for the people who enroll in
these classes so there's a link to that
below if you're interested in that sort
of thing I've also got courses on
curious these are sort of micro courses
these are for people who don't have
quite so much time and they want to you
know work their way through a video
lesson or series of lessons on classic
works and ideas with some you know
questions to test their their learning
and some handouts and links and things
like that we also did a lot of
curriculum development not only for
reason I oh but also for other clients
and organizations we offered a workshop
for one of the local radio stations here
that was pretty cool thing that we did
in 2016 so quite a lot that that got
done here been a pretty busy year and
this is so this is really our first you
know year that we've been in Milwaukee
for the entire time we're really happy
to be home and so that was 2016 so
what's coming up in 2017 let's talk
first about January already quite a bit
going on there so we begin the month
with a half-hour Hagel online Q&A
session if you're if you're interested
in Hagel and dialectics and in German
idealism you might want to come into
that we're now going to be using a link
to free conference call calm rather than
using google hangouts which is probably
going to make things a bit easier all
around and it'll allow us to bring more
people in if we have a larger group that
wants to meet that will be on the 11th
which is a wednesday 5 to 6 p.m. central
time so if you're in a different time
zone you want to take take note of that
then the next day we have our very first
talk of the year locally here in
brookfield which is a suburb of
milwaukee and it is in the worlds of
speculative fiction series it's on
Phillip Jose farmers River World Series
very cool set of books and I'm really
looking forward to that by the way we're
doing something new with this worlds of
speculative fiction series which is I'm
building out a website or building out
pages on the reason I owe website in
order to make it easier for the people
who want to participate in it to do so
there's going to be like resources and
links and you know when the video goes
up you'll see it there so if you're if
you're interested in that series you
probably want to connect up with the
reason I owe website those are the main
things going on there is there is one
other big thing that we're doing here
locally which is that we are in the
process it's not yet scheduled but we're
in the process of putting together
something like a stoic meet up there are
there many people who are interested in
contemporary stoicism and we are we've
decided that you know for the Milwaukee
area we're going to do the work to begin
that hopefully we'll find some other
people who are willing to step up in
time and and take it over but somebody
needs to get it started so it's going to
be under the auspices of the stomach
fellowship it'll be a meetup group so if
you're in the area
and you want to get together with other
people who are interested in in stoic
philosophy and its applications that
will be something that you're going to
want to check out it's going to be a
meetup group and you'll see
announcements for it on the reason I Oh
site what else have we got going in well
online courses the reason I Oh Academy I
mentioned that that there's the world
views and values class that I opened up
our pub publicized rather just a few
days ago and we're offering a special
coupon code for that that i'll put a
link to down below if you want to take
it and at a preferred price this month
that's great so this is a course that
was very popular when I developed it and
taught it for a college several years
ago it was in high demand from the
students because they really liked what
I did with it and people have been
watching those videos and saying oh I
wish I could be in that class well now
you can so if you're interested in that
sort of thing we go over Plato Epictetus
boethius Descartes Hobbs Russo
Wollstonecraft marks and Martin Luther
King and we take some some salute you
know selected works from each of those
so Martin Luther King letter from a
Birmingham jail parts of Plato's
Republic Bowie theses consolation of
philosophy Wollstonecraft's a
vindication of the rights of women some
some selections from it Hobbes Leviathan
you know all those sorts of things that
is available in the reason I Oh Academy
we're also going to be bringing out some
other courses and if I meet my ambitions
for the month you'll not only see a set
of courses on Aristotle's Nicomachean
ethics but also epictetus is discourses
if I don't get all of that done you'll
see the Aristotle stuff and then see the
epictetus stuff the month after that and
we're going to be continually adding new
courses over the the year I'll also be
adding some stuff to the half hour hey
course that's already in the reason I Oh
Academy if you're interested in that you
probably want to become a Patrian
subscriber because one of the perks is
that you get into that course for free
otherwise it's 175 so all of that is is
is going on for january hopefully i said
i'm doing it quite a bit of public
writing I when I you know as opposed to
academic writing I'll be doing some
editing work for stoicism today i don't
think i'll be publishing anything in the
the new site for stoicism today i will
be writing quite a bit in our axis
deanna wat EK and in the half hour Hagel
blog and i'm working on a piece for
policy of truth which is my friend
earphones blog that i mentioned i'm also
working on a piece that hopefully will
come out in the partially examined life
blog later this month i'm working out a
piece for another blog called aid alone
which is about ancient ancient culture
in general so we'll see how that goes
and i'll be answering some Korra
questions i'm like i also said to though
i'm working on that book stoic dog mata
concerning anger so I should talk a
little bit about that what are what are
dog model when you hear the word dog mob
right and you think about a belief or an
idea that is considered important and
something that you really should know
for a religion or a philosophy or
political creed or something like that
that's what with the Stoics had in mind
and one of the things that the Stoics
like to do was to not just provide you
these this sort of thing they would
teach right or right about but as a
learner you would want it you'd want to
memorize them you'd want to keep them
ready at hand in your mind so that when
you ran into a situation where suddenly
this could be useful you would be able
to bring it out and say AHA this is this
is what I need so I'm compiling a book
and I'll probably be doing a little bit
of
translation for it you know I read the
Greek and the Latin so I can I can you
know tweak them a bit to make them a
little bit more contemporary if need be
but that's hopefully going to come out
by the end of the month it's fortunate
january's got 31 days because there's a
lot of stuff we're trying to get done
I'm also going to be doing some academic
writing doing some some stuff on the
Stoics and some stuff on Aristotle i'm
not sure if i'll finish that by the end
of the month but we'll see videos this
is probably the thing you're most
interested in since you're watching this
on my channel i'm going to be bringing
out the remainder of the core concept
videos on Aristotle's Nicomachean ethics
which you have to do with book ten of
the Nick and McCain ethics which is
about pleasure and a few other things
I'm in pretty good shape to get the six
half hour hagel videos done for this
month and I'm going to be remastering
some of the existentialism videos and
inserting some breaks and to them
boosting the sound uncertain of them and
those you'll be able to find in my
history of ideas channel not in this
channel but the history of ideas channel
I'll also be doing some more of those
dr. Sadler responds videos there's
there's quite a few questions that I get
answered that I really should just have
a video response to so I can link to it
and people can watch it and then get
their questions answered or their issue
addressed I'm going to be doing some
more personal oriented videos some of
them about my philosophical development
you know phases I went through or or why
I'm committed to doing this kind of
philosophy some of them were more
general but like why I'm doing
philosophy on YouTube and we'll see what
else we can get done over the course of
the month what else we're also heavily
involved in doing some curriculum
development mostly focused on the
emotion of anger for various types of
clients we do a lot of discussion and
providing resources with that it's one
of my specialties so
that is what is going on in January of
2017 it already sounds like quite a bit
but fortunately it's early month let's
talk now about 2017 more broadly what
else is going on this year not just in
January so we already have some talks
lined up and we're going to be looking
to get a lot more talks lined up by the
way I should mention if you're
interested in having me come out and
speak at your institution or
organization go ahead and email me Greg
at reason I oh we're in the process of
filling up the calendar at present so
now is a really good time if you want
that sort of thing to get in contact
with me I'm already going to be giving a
talk in october at stoic on 2017 on i've
also got another truck coming up in
march on mary wollstonecraft or women's
history month those are already booked
and i'll be speaking at the st. and some
conference i think this is the sixth st.
anselm conference at st. Anselm's
college sponsored by the institute for
st. anselm studies I'll be talking about
Anselm and virtue out there that will be
I believe also in April in addition to
those we already have like I said some
of these library sponsored series set up
so the world's is speculative fiction
that's 12 lectures one each month on
some great classic or contemporary
science fiction horror fantasy author
there's a lot of cool stuff in there
philosophers in the midst of history
we're going to be doing a whole slew of
new philosophers as well and we're
starting a new series partnering with
another local library is it's it's
titled something like women whose works
you should have read and we're focusing
on female philosophers over the course
of history so you know Elizabeth of
Bohemia for example have one on Mary
Wollstonecraft there's going to be a lot
of great stuff in that you can you can
find out about that
looking at our calendar looking at the
website classes so the reason I owe
Academy like i mentioned we're now going
with teachable and that's where you're
going to find all of our longer more
substantive classes if you want shorter
stuff you can of course go to curious
and we have some some content on there
as well but the longer stuff is all
going to be available in the reason I
owe academy we have we have a one free
course and I may put another free course
in there the rest of them are are all at
some sort of level so i will probably be
bundling them together as well all that
stuff what i really want to talk about
is the content right so we're going to
be doing classes on great minds in in
philosophy great texts as well so can
have a lot of plato content coming out
over the course of the year a lot of
aristotle content not just nikka mccain
ethics I'm hoping that I might actually
get to the rhetoric right stoics we have
a we have an epictetus discourses course
that's going to be coming out but I'm
also going to be doing some work on
Seneca marcus aurelius on what we know
about the Stoics from diogenes Laertes
and cicero and all that sort of stuff
we're going to do some other great minds
along the way it probably like the card
Hobbs you know what we'll see who else
maybe Hume existentialism I'm going to
offer an actual class on that but we're
also going to have some standalone
courses on particular figures and text
like jean-paul Sartre or for treating
Nietzsche or you know certain
Kierkegaard we'll see who are able to
bring up I'm also going to be building
an ethics course well actually a whole
ethics curriculum this is one of the
things that I've been teaching for about
20 years so I've got a lot of material
and I've got a lot of other content that
I'm looking to put into it I've figured
out what works what doesn't work with
students so it's going to be some really
cool stuff and I'm going to focus mostly
on five main moral theories
various forms of egoism utilitarianism
deontology virtue ethics and ethics of
care but I may also delve into some
other stuff as as well we're hoping as
well to bring out some courses
specifically dealing with anger some of
them will be more hands-on some of them
will be more theoretical you know what
we know looking at various perspectives
on anger although really all of its
practical when you get down to it
because we all get angry and then if I
have the time / 2016 I'd actually like
to bring out a few courses working off
of that worlds of speculative fiction
thing dealing with some of the key
thinkers like I would love to do a
course for example on philip k dick or
on you know Tolkien or on you know a van
voy or some of these other great writers
who I really enjoy so we'll see if that
happens this is the big projection time
public writing I'm going to be working
with all of those various blogs and
platforms that I mentioned before and
we're looking to perhaps get into a few
others we'll see how that works I'm
sending out query letters to see if they
want me to write for them at this time
but you know I don't want to make any
big predictions and have them not come
true I will tell you this that I am
working on two popularly oriented books
that I would love to see come out by by
the end of the year one on stoicism and
anger and the resources that stomach
philosophy has for understanding
managing lessening dealing with anger
one working at the same sort of stuff
but from an Aristotelian perspective so
Aristotle on anger there's a lot of
great resources there as well and
academic writing I'm hoping that this
year I can actually get to all these
conference papers and things that I've
sent out before or things that I've been
sitting on I probably have anywhere from
like 20 to 30 potential articles some of
them
almost completely done sitting on my
hard drives that I just need to get
around to sending out to journals and
getting published I'm also going to be
working on my academically oriented
Aristotle's theory of anger book and I'm
hoping to get some more work done on the
Anselm and mercy and justice book which
I'm hoping would be a you know short
book like a hundred pages or so although
maybe it'll turn out to be a bit longer
what else we've got you know a lot of
video stuff coming out over the course
of the year I've already mentioned you
know half hour Hagel core concepts of a
lot of those coming out I'm going to be
doing more series like the epictetus
series that i did of close readings you
can expect to see for example
Aristotle's categories I'm going to give
it that sort of treatment again I'm
going to take des cartes meditations and
do that line by line sort of reading and
you notice that I'm wearing this the
sweater I don't know if you recognize it
at all but I'm going to be using this in
another series because you know for
years when I've been lecturing in the
classroom and people saw me with my hair
down and maybe if I take the glasses off
they would say what they would say that
o is the dude teaching philosophy so you
know it's not a pure resemblance there I
have to do a little bit of voice work
but you know give me a nice white
russian and some stuff to talk about and
maybe I'll do some filming with with
this as the dude we'll see we'll see how
it goes in any case that is what's
coming up in 2017 hope it is a great
enjoyable prosperous and productive year
for all of you and see you next month